schauen sie sich das besser nicht an
gehen sie weiter es gibt hier nichts zu
sehen wann immer wir diese sätze hören
ist unsere schaulust geweckt dann wollen
wir mit eigenen augen betrachten was
sich da unerhörtes da grausames ereignet
haben mag
das gilt nicht zuletzt von bildern des
terrors fast täglich werden sie uns
angeboten zugemutet mein heutiger gast
die berliner kunsthistorikerin charlotte
klonk forscht über bilder des terrors
und einen verantwortlichen umgang mit
ihnen nun hat sie ein buch geschrieben
terror wenn bilder zu waffen werden
ein wichtiges thema für uns alle
herzlich willkommen herzlichen dank für
die einladung
glock ich sprach von einer
unmenschlichen schaulust sie sind ja nun
ein mensch der sich beruflich schon sehr
lange mit bildern beschäftigt die
analysiert sind sie ein schaulustiger
mensch ich bin auf jeden fall ein
optischer mensch also visuelle eindrücke
sind unglaublich prägend für mich
unglaublich wichtig für mich aber
vielleicht gerade deshalb weil die
antennen da immer ausgefahren sind bin
ich auch sehr empfindlich
also diesen kitzel des grausamen der
stößt die ihr abo der cz
man hat keine faszination für mich das
ist etwas was ich wenn ich merke dass es
eine große faszination ausübt verstehen
möchte warum das auf manche menschen
menschen so wirkt die entscheidung das
eigene leben bildern zu widmen und dem
verstehen die ist ja oft auf einen
erlebnisse in der kindheit oder ein
schlüsselerlebnis zurückgezogen gab es
bei ihnen die idee dass
sagen wir ja bilder das ist das wenig
nämlich mein leben widmen möchte das ist
das was ich verstehen will ja spannende
frage ich habe oft darüber nachgedacht
wie das eigentlich komme ich bin mit
bildern aufgewachsen mein großvater ist
maler und ich habe diskussionen zwischen
einem vater und ihm mitbekommen
ich bin in kassel groß geworden da gibt
es wunderbare alte meister habe nun auch
das neunzehnte jahrhundert später durch
die hat die rektorin sehr gut
kennengelernt und dann natürlich alle 45
jahre die dokumente ich weiß zum
beispiel jetzt eine berühmte dokumente
über die ich jetzt im unterricht auch
viel rede die 72er dokumente standen wir
irgendwie mit meinen eltern auf dem
friedhof man lauter nackte menschen ich
fand das völlig unverständlich und
irgendwie konnten wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt meine eltern die das sehr
spannend fanden auch nicht gut erklären
das heißt eigentlich sind bilden immer
das gewesen was niemand mehr so richtig
erklären konnte was unverständlich blieb
die haben es zu studieren und erst sehr
viel später begriffen dass das
eigentlich auch die kraft der bilder ist
dieses nicht verstehen das unerhörte und
teilweise auch verstörende an bildern
das sind ja auch die bilder denen sie
ihre letzten forschungs jahre mit wird
haben bilder des terrors die uns
verstören die uns anziehen die uns
selbst erschrecken würden sie denn sagen
dass bilder des schreckens wie es terror
bilder sind diesen schrecken auch immer
an den betrachter weitergeben
also immer ich also ich natürlich diese
bilder haben eine wirkung in dem kontext
in dem sie erscheinen manchmal haben sie
es auch aus den bildern selbst heraus
aber ob man darauf immer reagieren
möchte und will das engt glaube ich doch
sehr von einzelnen umständen man kann
sich auch wappen gegen solche bilder
man kann sagen kenne ich schon habe ich
immer gesehen oder man kann gleich den
feind fest machen dann sind sie auch
erst mal wieder weg man muss sich mit
denen nicht unbedingt auseinandersetzen
aber wenn es zu dieser es gibt ja bilder
und wir werden einige davon heute sehen
und auch vielleicht sehen müssen
die ein schrecken weitergeben wo man das
schock
der person die man selbst sieht man
empfindet sie gleichsam selbst in das
empathische effekte und warum sind
bilder da so viel stärker als texte zum
beispiel ja das ist ne das ist ein
interesse haben sie auch völlig recht
das ist eine ganz interessante frage wir
erleben uns körperlich in der empfindung
von bildern und daher spüren wir den
abgebildeten körper im eigenen körper
klarer als in texten und das macht
glaube ich die wirkung aus also da gibt
es natürlich mittlerweile ganz gute
forschung zu und das kann man so
festhalten
und wir reagieren effektiver auf bilder
als wir es auf sprache also nicht alle
und man kann das wiedergibt wieder
andere fälle aber doch in der regel ja
da gibt es da effekte die sie vielleicht
auch als historikerin kunsthistorikerin
beschreiben können dass man sagt ge
stumpfen ab denn man könnte ja sagen
sobald wir die medien betrachten uns
ihnen aussetzen sind wir überflutet von
bildern des schreckens so dass diese
wirkung sich vielleicht auch verläuft
oder schwächer wird er auch dazu gibt es
natürlich forschungen ich von mir
sondern von medienwissenschaftlern das
phänomen der abstumpfung und überflutung
zu viel des gleichen bildes die gibt es
ganz bestimmt auf der anderen seite wird
die natürlich immer wieder durchbrochen
wenn es um ereignisse geht die dann doch
sehr nah an die eigene
lebenswirklichkeit heranrücken
also ist die nähe zu der eigenen
lebenswirklichkeit die frage hätte das
auch ich sein können ein wichtiger
aspekt bei der frage wie uns bilder
betreffen
ich glaube da haben sie völlig recht ja
es gibt nun eine sehr klassische
darstellung des schreckens von einer
person die von diesem schrecken auch
betroffen war dennis der schrecken fand
in ihrem plan statt das ist die
darstellung des romans von guernica von
pablo picasso ein vielleicht
unübertroffenes bild in der darstellung
von schrecken was was macht dieses bild
so besonders und so großartig
ja also wie bei bildern die berühmt
werden es war schon ein berühmter
künstler hängen immer auch die umstände
stark mit der wirkung zusammen dieses
bild wurde von der spanischen republik
in auftrag gegeben also bzw
picasso wurde beauftragt für die
weltausstellung 1937 ein bild zu malen
und dann kam der luftangriff auf ghana
ist war bürgerkrieg in spanischen
republik also die truppen francos hatten
um unterstützung der deutschen und
italienischen luftwaffe gebeten und die
hat eben dieses völlig
völkerrechtswidrige bombardement auf die
baskische stadt guernica so liebte 730
picasso hat sich dann ganz schnell
entschieden diesen völkerrechtlichen und
dieses morden der zivilbevölkerung zum
thema zu machen für die weltausstellung
also die umstände waren günstig und dann
macht er es in einem format was zu
dieser zeit ungewöhnlich war und und das
ist vielleicht jetzt das entscheidende
er benutzt eine bildsprache die sowohl
modern ist aber auch klassische silicon
o graffy sagen wir also formsprache
zitiert so dass es verständlich ist dass
es ihm leid geht wenn ich dieses bild
und ich habe es auch schon oft
betrachtet sehr als laie dann denke ich
es gibt dort engel und es gibt die
gequälte kreatur rechts und links sehen
wir die gequälte kreatur und von rechts
oben diese gestalt sie ist fast wie ein
erschreckte enge der daraufhin absieht
ist da nicht auch irgendwie ein leiden
zwischen mensch und göttern und die
frage wieso viel grausamkeit überhaupt
möglich sein kann stand also ich sehe
die engel nicht also immer das ist ja
ein dreigeteiltes bild in der mitte im
zentrum steht so ein kegel der hat auch
ein licht teil rechts und einen dunklen
teil
und in diesem kegel ist sozusagen das
ganze leid symbolisch also der ist unten
links der ausgestreckt schon der
gefallene krieger die spanische republik
also die krieger der spanischen republik
mit zerbrochenem speer darüber im
zentrum eigentlich das tier und das
entscheidend ist ja ein picassos
formsprache der zeigt die die
geschundene die geschundenen leiber
nicht mit blutspritzern und wunden
sondern mit verstorbenen formen und das
pferd steht für ihn immer für light das
steht auch viel leid also unschuldiges
leiten es zugefügt wird und dann haben
wir rechts
man kann diese dreiecke die oben und
rechts raus kommen als feuer flamme
sehen und im grunde hat man die
feuersbrunst der stadt guernica da mit
dem um hilfe rufenden menschen und
eigentlich sind diese ich glaube dass
sie als engel bezeichnet haben das sind
eigentlich fliehende und verschreckten
schon erstarrte menschen aus der stadt
guernica und ganz links noch es und da
eben wieder ganz klasse ist es
eigentlich ein triptychon klassische
einteilung haben wir die das jammer um
die den verlust und die verlorenen in
form ganz klassisch ein abgesang peter
also maria mit dem jesuskind die mutter
die ihr kind hält und es ist
wahrscheinlich auch das größte leid was
man sich vorstellen was das kind was sie
jetzt schon hier so ganz faszinierend
verkörpern und auch erklären ist ja dass
bilder unglaublich komplex sind wir
könnten wahrscheinlich jetzt noch eine
stunde oder vier stunden über dieses
geld sprechen
sie sind mindestens so komplex wie texte
unsere kinder werden in der schule
unterrichtet texte zu verstehen
texte zu deuten zu interpretieren sie
werden kaum darin unterrichtet bilder zu
verstehen und zu interpretieren es gibt
eine riesen unwucht in unserer kultur
zwischen text verstehen wie wir das
lernen und bild verstehen warum ist das
eigentlich so
ja es erstaunliche bilder mehr denn je
so eine große rolle in unserem leben
spielen
ich habe kann ihnen das nicht erklären
ich kann nur sagen das ist jemandem wie
mir natürlich sehr am herzen liegt dass
das bild verständnis wesen ich glaube
dass das bild verständnis wesentlich
weniger ausgeprägt ist als das
textverständnis texten begegnen menschen
viel kritischer fiel reflektierter
bilder gerade fotos von zeitgeschehen
scheinen immer unmittelbar auskunft zu
geben über das was sie darstellen ist es
die idee dass ein bild in einem
unmittelbaren zusammenhang mit seinem
gegenstand steht weil das ist ja bei
manchen bei den meisten bildern gar
nicht der fall jedes bild ist ja etwas
anderes als das was es darstellt
sonst ist es kein bild und doch haben
die menschen die idee dass da eine
unmittelbare beziehung besteht ja genau
und da fragt man sich natürlich wieso
die unmittelbarer ist das auch eine
kamera dazwischen also bei fotografien
eine kamera dazwischen geschaltet wenn
man den augenzeugenbericht hat wäre der
computer also der stift oder und das
tippen wir sind das wort dazwischen
geschaltet es gibt natürlich mit der
kamera und dem vernehmen aber auch da
ist es selektieren aber jedem
augenzeugenbericht treten die leute
schon von vornherein kritischer entgegen
als einem selektierenden aus wählenden
foto wir sind hier heute in einer kultur
und werden ihn ja groß die visueller ist
denn je denken sie an die sozialen
netzwerke an instagram facebook trägt
das bild ja schon gleichsam im namen
dieses versäumnis unseren kindern
beizubringen wie man bilder versteht ich
meine sie als mensch der ein
aufklärendes buch über bilder bestehen
hat möchte man da nicht eine
gesellschaftliche initiative man sagt
wir müssen bild erziehung ins zentrum
unserer pädagogischen bemühungen stellen
ja ich glaube das tun aber wir also das
tun wer kunsthistoriker ganz sicher und
es wurden auch viele kollegen und ich
glaube auch dass es in der schule
angekommen es also ich denke dass also
ich erinnere mich sogar dass ich mal
kurse im deutschunterricht hatte wo man
sich kommunikationsstrategien von
bildern in der werbung angeguckt hat
also ich glaub so ganz analphabeten sind
wir darauf
nun gibt es eine form von bildern in
denen diese unmittelbarkeit zwischen
gegenstand und abbildung besonders stark
ist das sind die fotografien die haben
den stärksten unmittelbarkeit eindruck
und diese fotografien sind natürlich
auch für das worüber wir heute sprechen
wollen am wichtigsten nämlich terror
terror darstellungen ist es eigentlich
ein zufall dass das zeitalter der
fotografie ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts mit dem zeitalter des
modernen terrors fast gleichzeitig
beginnt also da sind
überschneidungen weil die modernen
technologien unglaublich wichtig sind
für die entwicklung des modernen terrors
also die entwicklung der eisenbahn des
telegrafen netz das ist wichtig wenn man
eine im untergrund agierende gruppe ist
die irgendwie sich organisieren muss und
nicht entdeckt werden kann dann muss man
schnell über ländergrenzen kommen dann
muss man kommunizieren können aber das
spannende als ich mir das mal genauer
angeguckt hat wie sich das eigentlich
verhält mit den bildern des terrors seit
beginn wurde deutlich es fängt sogar
noch vor der fotografie an
eigentlich fängt es an in dem augenblick
wo die zeitungen illustriert werden und
das ist erst ab mitte des 19
jahrhunderts das vergessen wir oft also
es hängt doch mit bildlicher
darstellbarkeit in massenmedien zusammen
genau aber das sind am anfang bis zum
ende des 19 jahrhunderts stahlstich
holzstiche es klingt komisch aber dass
eine bestimmte technik aber noch keine
fotografien das dauert eine weile bis
die fotografie umgesetzt werden konnte
in die drucke das wesen des modernen
terrors so wie sie es beschreiben und
auch darlegen besteht ja nicht darin
dass die tat selbst unbedingt
wirksamkeit erzeugen soll sondern die
kommunikation der tat soll den effekt
soll den effekt hervorrufen nämlich den
schrecken in der breite das heißt also
dass die kommunikation der tat das
eigentliche mittel des terrorismus ist
verstehe ich sie richtig
ja da bin ich nicht die erste die das
sagt das ist seit geraumer zeit so ein
diktum in der forschung eine terror
forschung
aber also dass terror eine
kommunikationsstrategie vor allem es ist
eigentlich schon deshalb klar weil es
eben eine militärisch unterlegenen
gruppe ist die das gewaltmonopol des
staates herausfordert und wenn das der
fall ist kommt man mit den waffen ja
sowieso nicht gegen den die macht die
man herausfordert an
also braucht man andere mittel und
verstärker die waffen bleiben natürlich
die tötungs instrumente sind die
eigentlichen waffen aber die
entscheidenden mittel das sind schon die
bilder und das wird in der forschung
gesagt aber ich wollte es mir mal
genauer angucken was das eigentlich für
die strategie bedeutet wie wir darauf
reagiert gibt es entwicklungen und man
könnte doch dann auch sagen und das
bringt uns ja in die ethik der
darstellung sofort rein
ein terroranschlag von dem es keine
bilder gibt der nicht dokumentiert war
ist der hat sein ziel schon verfehlt
nein das kann man so nicht sagen es gibt
die es gibt manchmal ziele dienen
da geht es um ein direktes ziel und es
geht nicht um die verbreitung in den
medien also nicht um das erzeugen von
angst und schrecken in der bevölkerung
das gibt es immer noch und gab es auch
tränen wort beschreiben wie ich der sich
natürlich nur auf die bilder
konzentriert denn nimmt diese anschläge
nicht mehr wahr
das muss man auch sagen das ist dann
sozusagen ein blinder fleck aber die
mehrzahl der terrortaten im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die zielen schon darauf eine
die bevölkerung des staates dem man die
stabilisieren möchte irgendwie zu
verunsichern um über diese
verunsicherung dann entsprechende
repressionsmaßnahmen der staaten zu
bewirken die dann wiederum zu aufständen
führen und so das ganze system irgendwie
zum kollaps bringt erschrecken viral
wird gleichsam eine wichtige spannung
die um die ihr buch kreist und die sie
besprechen ist die zwischen drei punkten
in der terror darstellung einmal gibt es
eine informationspflicht und ein
aufklärungsinteresse
andere mal gibt es ein
persönlichkeitsschutz in der darstellung
sowohl der opfer als auch der täter und
der dritte punkt ist so wie ich es
verstanden habe
die propaganda wirkung als intendierte
wirkung der täter und den immer wenn ein
terror anschlag passiert stehen wir in
dieser spannung zwischen informationen
persönlichkeitsschutz und propaganda
wirkung ist dass das dreieck das sonst
heute bedingt ja also ich meine und
keiner kein element kann hier in
besonderer weise unter den tisch fallen
oder betont werden die sind wirklich was
haben sie wunderbar skizziert das ist
wirklich das spannungsverhältnis in dem
wir uns bewegen und was wir immer wieder
neu austarieren müssen denn es steht
außer frage dass bald ein anschlag in
unserem umfeld passiert oder in einem
umfeld wo wir uns vorstellen könnten
dass wir da hätten auch gerade sein
können dann wollen wir wissen
ich glaube das ist ganz normal dann
wollen wir wissen was ist da passiert
hätte mich das betreffen können wie
hätte ich mich sichern können das ist so
ganz ganz normale und ich finde auch
ganz rationale bedürfnisse und bilder
vermitteln das ja ganz gut und es ist
natürlich ein dilemma in dem wir uns
alle als desorientiert oder zumindest
als herausgefordert erfahren machen wir
doch mal die probe aufs exempel
ein extremes beispiel trotzdem wollen
wir darüber reden
das ist die fotografie des gefangenen
james foley der nach zweijähriger
geschenken gefangenschaft 2014 vom bs
ermordet wurde
dieses bild hier ist teil eines videos
das dann zeigt wie hervorgeht
tatsächlich rituell enthauptet wird ist
hier diese spannung für sie noch gewahrt
ist jedoch eine informationspflicht wie
steht es um die persönlichkeitsrechte
und den propaganda zweck ein guter punkt
also hier ist es natürlich hier ist der
fall das sind und da glaube ich ist
dieses dreieck der spannung das
skizziert haben auch nicht mehr
tragfähig weil das ist ja im unterschied
zu bildern die in den medien erscheinen
nun bild was komplett vom ps generiert
ist und an der stelle glaube ich kaum
andere fragen zum tragen
man weiß von vornherein dass das ein
propaganda video ist dass auf der einen
seite die bevölkerung der westlichen
zivilisation die sich mit folie
identifiziert journalist war muss man
dazu genau verunsichert und auf der
anderen seite natürlich sympathisanten
anwerben durch besondere brillanz und
besondere kraft mal wenn man so will
und im moment wo gerade dieses video ich
hätte es hier nicht gezeigt weil ich
glaube dass die konflikte immer noch
nicht zu ende sind im moment wo diese
konflikte schwelen ist es ein
riesenerfolg wenn dieses video mit
vielen klicks abgerufen wird
das ist dann der erfolg für die
organisation es ist ja von denen notiert
das ist der große unterschied und meine
frage an diese bilder ist was welche
informationen geben sie uns eigentlich
die nicht komplett durchregiert durch
regieanweisung des es vorgegeben ist und
wollen wir uns dürfen wir uns sogar
diesen bildern aussetzen meine antwort
ist nein ganz interessant ich nehme
waren dem was sie sagen es gibt immer
eine wesentliche frage die wir uns
stellen müssen wer hat diese bilder
erzeugt weil hinter dieser erzeugung
immer ein interesse steht das niemals
unschuldig ist so ist der erste
orientierungspunkt wenn ich mir zum
beispiel als konsument oder als medien
verantwortlich hat die entscheidung vor
mir steht veröffentlichte dieses bild
die erste frage wer hat dieses bild
haben sorgt dass das richtig er ganz
sicher und die zweite frage ist doch
aber auch die bediene ich hier nur ein
voyeurismus oder es hat ja auch einen
edukativen einen ethischen nutzen zu
zeigen zu welchen schreckenstaten
menschen fähig sind es ist ja nicht nur
so dass dieses bild zum beispiel zeigt
eine erniedrigung eines menschen
sie führt uns auch vor augen wo zu der
es in der lage und willens ist hat
dieses argument verstehe ich nicht ich
meine es reicht ja zu wissen es passiert
ja auch nicht wesentlich mehr in diesem
film als zu wissen dass ein orange
gekleideter mann kniet in der weißen
weiten wüstenlandschaft verbleiben
gezeigt wird dahinter ein schwarzer
mörder mit messer in der hand der ihn
dann nach zitieren des korans und
rechtfertigungen in englisch das ist für
die sicherheitsdienste interessant wer
ist der täter aber nicht
für uns dann enthauptet wird und dann
hört man irgendwann dass die enthauptung
selbst im film nicht gezeigt wird was
kann uns dieses dieser film eigentlich
noch mehr erzählen als das was ich jetzt
gezielt auf das kann man skizzieren muss
man diesen film sich dann noch angucken
und ich verstehe dieses argument nicht
das habe ich oft schon gehört dieses
argument dass man sich diese bilder
angucken muss um zu verstehen zu welchem
streul taten diese menschen fähig sind
denn erstens können wir das hören wir
sehen nicht mehr in den bildern und
zweitens ist da muss man jetzt auch
nicht kalt bemühen aber unsere
vorstellungskraft unendlich groß wir
brauchen nicht all das erfahren was wir
uns vorstellen können ziemlich erfahren
das stimmt das leuchtet mir einer sie
sagen da ist eigentlich gar kein
weiterer zweck zumindest kein
informationsleck zumal die vorstellung
wie oft noch grausamer sind als die
bilder selbst nichtsdestotrotz könnte
man darüber auch argumentieren dass es
ja auch eine dokumentation interesse
gibt immerhin wird gezeigt was mit
diesen menschen geschieht es könnte ja
sonst auch nur erzählt werden oder
behauptet werden
also es wird ja eine faktizität
dokumentiert die ein informationswert
hat aber die faktizität ist doch da muss
die denn dokumentiert werden ich meine
es ist grausam genug für die familie zu
wissen dass der enthauptet wurde
also das ist nochmal der weiteren punkt
was passiert eigentlich wenn wir über
diese bilder reden als werden diese
menschen keine menschen mit familien
geliebten freundin nachgestellt anleger
müssen das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe
dass ist ja ein sprichwort dass wir alle
kennen ihn ja gut aber das ist ja das
ist ein interessantes eine interessante
behauptung im zusammenhang mit hoch
durch inszenierten bildern
denn man kann alles inszeniert es ist
schon interessant weil ich merke wie im
gespräch ich meine eigene wahrnehmung
und mein eigenes beurteilen verschiebt
durch ihre argumente würden sie denn so
weit gehen wenn man den punkt macht und
dann machen sie im buch das
entscheidende an diesen taten sind jetzt
nicht die taten sondern die bilder die
darüber zirkulieren dass die menschen
die sich solche bilder und vielleicht
auch videos live videos im netz
anschauen teil der mittäterschaft sind
eine verantwortung für die tat selbst
mittragen
also rechtlich ist das schwer das kann
man so nicht behaupten aber ich habe es
eine unfreiwillige beteiligung genannt
weil man sich glaube ich in dem
augenblick nicht klar ist dass man
eigentlich die täter unterstützt und
gerade in diesem zusammenhang mit der
enthauptung des videos dass ihr es da
ist ganz klar gewesen nach dem großen
erfolg und das war ein großer medien
erfolg im westen die enthauptung von von
voll ich finds ja immer noch in
großbritannien war das zeigen diese
bilder darunter lagen das angucken das
verbreiten dieser bilder verboten
und trotzdem haben mehrere millionen
menschen gesehen also zwei prozent der
bevölkerung lehrbuch obwohl ist eine
verbotene handlung weil ich meine merkt
man wie verbote hier überhaupt nicht
greifen und wie sinnlos das ist und
gerade anheizen und dann noch mehr zum
zum erfolg der täter beitragen
aber nach diesem großen erfolg haben ja
noch eine ganze reihe von von von
enthauptungen und als dann so und die
aufmerksamkeit schwelle so ein bisschen
sank war so eine abstumpfung effekt
eingetreten ist und musste dann mit der
nächsten steigerung kommen die
verbrennung des jordanischen flug
piloten bei lebendigen körper laible
übersteigerung schleife es muss noch
grausamer noch schlimmer werden wenn der
erfolg da ist um wieder aufmerksamkeit
zu bekommen und als das dann auch vorbei
war kam dann die zerstörung von palmyra
also man sieht das ziel schon auf
aufmerksamkeit und je mehr
aufmerksamkeit beim dem widmen desto
größer der erfolg ist interessant das
heißt einige der klickt ist teil eines
eskalationsgefahr weil er diese schleife
befördert und weiter antreibt
da muss man sich nichts vormachen
eine sehr wichtige erkenntnis sie haben
davon gesprochen wichtig ist erstmal
sich zu fragen wer diese bilder macht
hier wurden die bilder von terroristen
gemacht und unser gesamtes terror unsere
gesamte terror bild vorstellung ist
derzeit ja dominiert vom islamistischen
terror
das ist das was uns zuerst in den kreis
kommt wir beide jetzt mit unserer
bundesdeutschen biografie haben noch
ganz andere bilder des terrors gesehen
und haben uns von ihnen beeindrucken
lassen die auch von anderen menschen
zirkuliert wurden da wollen wir uns mal
zwei anschauen nämlich die sogenannten
fahndungsfotos des raf terrors der ende
der 70er jahre in der bundesrepublik
seinen höhepunkt erreichte erinnern sie
sich noch persönlich an diese fotos den
banken und den supermärkten hingen ich
sie auch waschen nicht also ich erinnere
mich sogar ich ist mir ist das heute
fast peinlich aber ich erinnere mich
dass ich mit meinen als junges mädchen
mit meinen freundinnen an der
straßenbahnhaltestelle stand da waren
die groß auf der litfaßsäule und wir uns
ausgesucht haben viel schöner ist als
wären das kontaktanzeigen also werden
gar nicht mehr begriffen um was ist
eigentlich geht ja ich weiß noch als
diese bilder hin mit meiner mutter oft
zur bank gegangen da hingen diese raf
polster und ich fragte mal mutter wir
sind diese menschen und die antwort die
sie mir grad da war ich fünfeinhalb
sagte die sind böse und ich kann mich
noch meine mich erinnern zu können zu
sagen so böse sehen die doch gar nicht
aus denn das sind ja keine dämonen das
waren die freunde meiner schwester
design auch so aus ist das dann eine
fehlgeleitete täter darstellung auch von
seiten des bka des kriminalamtes die so
etwas zirkulieren lässt also erstmal
glaube ich dass es fahndungsfotos jeder
staat hat immer schon auch in vor
demokratischen zeiten das interesse
gehabt zu wissen wer eigentlich seine
gegner sind und danach zu fahnden
aber als ich mir das länger angeguckt
haben gerade wenn man den ausgangspunkt
dieser also wenn man diesem größte groß
angelegte kampagne aber die größte die
ist jäger fahndungs kampagne war diese
hierzu den rf tätern in den 70er jahren
wenn man die noch so gut kennt und weiß
das eigentlich fast jeder der eben nicht
also angesagt frauen die eben nicht fünf
frisuren tragen und männern die bisschen
bart und lange haare haben sind geraten
durch bilder wie diese in verdacht weil
es ja so viel gefahren und so und das
interessante bei den bildern ist ja auch
dass sie oft aus dem privaten kontext
kam vor der tat bilder sind oder familie
wurde gefragt freunde passbilder aus dem
führerschein
die wenigsten sind offizielle bilder
sieht man ganz gut also komme gleich
nochmal gucken aber das interessante ist
dass das eigentlich grundsätzlich glaube
ich mit fahndungsbildern so ist es gibt
nicht das böse gesicht damit es sind
menschen zu sehen die häufig aus der
mitte der gesellschaft kommen oder wie
jetzt aus den aus der muslimischen
bevölkerung und dann ist wiederum die
gefahr sehr groß dass eine große
friedliche bevölkerung stigmatisiert das
unter generalverdacht gesetzt wird also
auch hier ein ethisches bedenken sobald
man fahndungsfotos die typisiert sind
die ein allgemein oder wieder fit barren
typus darstellen geraten sehr sehr viele
menschen automatisch unter verdacht die
geht man denn mit fahndungsfotos und
gibt es da eine technik dass man sagt
man in die versiert sie so stark dass
das nicht passieren kann meiner meinung
nach ich habe jetzt wirklich nicht das
bundeskriminalamt gefragt oder andere
behörden hirseart aber ich habe mir
angeguckt was ich gesehen habe über
unterschiedliche kontexte also england
deutschland amerika und ich glaube es
gibt überhaupt keine konventionen dafür
zum beispiel neuerdings sehen wir öfter
mehrere bilder von manchmal den
anschlagsort dann den täter noch in
westlicher kleidung dann vielleicht
schon mit religiösen attributen das ist
geradezu heute also mehrere abbildung
des gleichen täters
was ist aber auch nicht einfacher macht
weil man dann sich fragt was wird
eigentlich eine geschichte erzählt vom
westlich angepassten menschen zum
radikalen religiösen der dann die tat
begeht das ist ja eine geschichte erst
einmal die wiedererkennbarkeit dann ja
gar nicht mehr gegeben ist wenn da drei
typen sind und man sagt dass ich ja gar
nicht derselbe mensch
die verwandlung oft sehr groß ist ja
wohl nur kurz zwei bilder aus dem
gleichen kontext betrachten da ist der
bild geber ein anderer nämlich die
terrororganisation selbst die
kommunikationssituation also umgedreht
und das sind bilder aus der geiselnahme
von hanns martin schleyer der
arbeitgeber präsident im herbst 1970 im
abstand von zwei wochen aufgenommen das
erste bild rechts ist das erst
aufgenommen und das zweite zwei wochen
danach ganz andere bilder einmal ein
erniedrigt im schlafanzug oder im hemd
gezeigt der mensch das andere mal im
anzug was hat sich da verändert was
wollte der rat erst anderes
kommunizieren ja also auf dem rechten
bild das erste bild das ist ein tag nach
der nach der entführung aufgenommen
polaroid bild was ja auch jetzt im
original haben sieht man dass eine rote
jacke an hat weil das in seinem versteck
spätere drf gefunden wurde
da knüpft die rf noch an meine kollegin
die historikerin petra gehhilfen
wunderbar ausgearbeitet an die build
strategien der roten brigaden in italien
an die mit erniedrigung bildern von
entführten industriemagnaten große
erfolge bei der bevölkerung gefeiert
haben
das sind so erniedrigung bilder also der
sich soll der schadenfreude gebäck wird
ja jetzt habe ich uns diesen mächtigen
mann mal gezeigt war der arbeitgeber
präsident die hoffnung war schon dass
der auch für die ersten großen
aussperrungen im bundesdeutschen gebiet
verantwortlich war da war glaube ich
schon die hoffnung dass steve für die
eigene sache zu erzeugen um ganz 2 und
das lief schief
unter sich aus verschiedenen gründen war
nämlich einmalig in der geschichte und
auch sehr umstritten die bundesregierung
mit im deutschen presse verband presse
also eine nachrichtensperre vereinbart
hat die sich mehr oder weniger gehalten
wurde das ist ja eine freiwillige
vereinbarung als das bild dann aber doch
über das ausland erst glaube ich dann
aber auch in der bild zeitung an die
öffentlichkeit kam bei der auf streife
sich also es gab überhaupt keine
sympathie kundgebung sondern eine große
welle von mitleid
einen menschen der so dargestellt ist
und daraufhin und das ist das standard
die rf ihre strategie geändert und er
erscheint in den weiteren bildern im
anzug gekämmt gefasst
ein schritt zurück getreten sollten also
und wir sehen ja heute geisel
darstellungen auch in verschiedensten
kontexten vor terroristen auch immer
bedenken was ist die
kommunikationsstrategie der terroristen
wollen sie den kreisel die geisel
bloßstellen wollen sie sie als ein von
uns darstellen oder wollen sie als
vielleicht auch dem objekt der absoluten
macht weil diese 31 tage auf diesem
plakat sagen ja auch so lange können wir
ihn halten und ihr findet uns nicht also
dinge die man sich ja gar nicht bewusst
macht so als nachrichten konsument alles
sehr kalkuliert alles mit einer
strategie dahinter ja ich glaube die
strategie hier ist im moment entwickelt
worden von der es in der reaktion aber
so ist es ja wie im wie im krieg waffen
produzieren und vorher sinne gegen man
muss die strategie geändert werden das
haben die gemacht das entscheidende was
ich hier glaube ich noch einmal betonen
möchte es der unterschied zwischen
diesen geiselnahme bildern und zum
beispiel den enthauptung bekannte sind
ja auch geiselnahmen james foley war ein
entführter in der großen anzahl der
geiselnahmen in der zweiten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gibt einen
merkwürdigen packt auch nicht sehr
komfortablen zwischen entführten und
entführern
das heißt die entführten wissen dass
wenn die bilder in umlauf geraten das
ist noch eine hoffnung dass vielleicht
sie doch noch freigekauft frei oder
legen sie nicht aufgegeben werden dass
man sich an sie noch erinnert die
geiselnahmen die langen geiselnahmen im
libanon da waren die leute zum 25 jahre
verschwunden da warten dass
lebenserhaltende maßnahmen diese bilder
auch für die familien die gebangt haben
der große unterschied zu den
behauptungen des videos die im grunde
als akw 2004 im irak begonnen hat das
deb dieser merkwürdige packt aufgegeben
es geht nicht mehr um handel und
verhandlung sondern es geht wirklich um
die tötung und dem also die tötung
passiert damit die bilder
in umlauf geraten können das ist ja
anders ganz entscheidende verschiebung
in der kommunikation sind und wie man
auch in dem ziel mit dem geisel genommen
werden wenn ich sie richtig verstehen
eines der interessantesten ergebnisse
für mich als leser ihres buches ist dass
sie sagen es gibt ein extrem stabiles
muster über alle medien revolution
hinweg wie wir mit terrorakten umgehen
und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
ist dass ein dreier schritt erstmals
wird der akt dokumentiert dann wird eine
kontrolle illusion oder ein kontroll
bild gezeigt dass man mit dem akt
umgehen kann und das dritte ist es wird
ein täter präsentiert der dann auch
gewisse rachegelüste oder zumindest
aufklärungs erwartungen weg ist dass der
dreischritt der immer noch passiert
erstmal das attentat zeigen dann die
kontrollsituation zeigen und dann den
täter zeigen
ja das ist es eigentlich frustrierende
gewesen für mich am anfang ich habe
angefangen mir mal die bilder aus der
tiefe der geschichte anzugucken also vom
späten neunzehnten jahrhundert an bis in
die gegenwart und dachte wie man das so
macht als konzentrieren da sehe ich eine
entwicklung da verändert sich was das
wird interessant die veränderung den
wandel darzustellen
und da gab es keinen wandel da gibt es
keine gleich von anfang an im 19
jahrhundert gibt es das was ich ein bild
muster nennen dieses bild muss da
besteht darin dass es zunächst eben
bilder vom anschlagsort geht an und da
ist auch wirklich das bedürfnis deutlich
noch zu spüren so nah wie es geht an den
tatort heranzukommen
und dann kommt aber gleich schon
vielleicht ist das ganze natürlich die
erste distanzierung strategie es werden
der funktionierende staat organisiert
sich selbst ich haben uns das gleich mal
konkret an
es gibt das erste bild und das ist
vielleicht der anschlag der letzten
jahrzehnte vielleicht auch das
jahrhunderts der anschlag auf das world
trade center
das ist erstmal die dokumentation des
anschlags aber es ist ja noch sehr viel
mehr als eine dokumentation das bild
wurde in fast allen globalen medien als
dieses bild auch gezeigt es hat ja auch
eine unglaubliche ästhetische kraft das
sollten wir nicht verleugnen
naja dass das ist eben glaube ich der
grund warum das
der französische historiker hat das
herausgefunden 93 prozent der
amerikanischen zeitung hatten am
nächsten tag auf der titelseite dieses
foto aus den vielen vielen vielen
hundert wie sie hätten wählen können was
ich meine natürlich ist man sieht beide
türme sind betroffen es ist eine
explosion es ist eine zeit nähe aber
gibt es noch andere effekte die dieses
bild so ikonisch werden ließ ja was
dieses bild auszeichnet ist bis haben
andere bilder aber erstmal dieser große
formale kontrast zwischen der feuerwerke
also der ist gerade der einschlag dem
zweiten tor passiert vor dieses feuerrot
vor dem vor dem blauen ja ganz stillen
septemberhimmel wieder in den garagen
klar ja mal sein kann so ganz friedlich
und das ist allein schon erstmal erstmal
farblichen kontrast auch ein formaler
kontrast hier auch noch mit dem gelb
sozusagen unten besonders betont dann
hat man diese rot blau gelb
das ist schon kräftig und was dieses
bild auszeichnet neben der schwarzen
rußwolke die schon hoch zieht dass das
leid unten in der stadt komplett
ausgespart ist das macht es so enorm
wichtig ansieht noch niemanden der
betroffenen ihre das ist also schon auch
eine form der distanzierung einerseits
wird es klar dokumentiert seine
andererseits man sieht das leid nicht
sehr interessant
der zweite schritt der staat
handlungsfähig er kann die situation in
den griff bekommt das wäre das zweite
bild von nine eleven
das sind jetzt natürlich die heroischen
feuerwehrleute von ihnen sehr viele
ikonische bilder gibt aber es ist
natürlich jetzt hier auch schon etwas
zweites zu sehen nämlich die konkret
betroffenen ja die aber nicht die toten
also die haben wir nicht gesehen
da gibt es keine bilder sondern es sind
immer die verletzten denen geholfen wird
das ist schon noch sich hier natürlich
besonders heroisch in dem sinne dass er
weggetragen wird manchmal sieht man nur
die rettungswagen und die rettungsleute
etwas maschineller sozusagen hier aber
das kümmern
man ist nicht allein gelassen das heißt
da ist auch schon trost drin in dem leid
hier und natürlich auch der ruis muss
der rettung der durch den staub noch mal
verdeutlicht die kommen direkt aus dem
geschehen selbst ja ich war mutige
menschen die natürlich auch gefragt
worden und dann gibt es den dritten
schritt der täter schritt der hat jetzt
in diesem fall besonders lange gedauert
und auch eine besonders mutmaßlichen
befriedigung geschaffen das sind jetzt
originalbilder der navy seals aus dem
wohnhaus von osama bin laden damals in
pakistan die dann auch zirkulierten und
freigegeben wurden allerdings auch hier
das opfer wurde selbst nie gezeigt so
weit ich informiert
und darum ich meinen sie ich fand das
damals eine unglaublich kluge und
sinnvolle entscheidung der
obama-regierung das opfer also den
erschossenen nicht zu zeigen es wundert
sie auch das ist interessant dass das
immer noch so ein großes bedürfnis weil
ich mich immer gefragt habe was hätte
dieses bild denn schon zeigen können ein
erschossener gewaltsam zu tode gekommen
der mensch sieht aus wie ein gewaltsam
zu tode gekommen
ich kann ihnen glaube ich sagen was
meine erwartungen ernährt dass dieses
bild hätte gezeigt werden müssen und das
ist das hollywood skript dass der
bösewicht umgebracht wird er und dass
man das auch zeigen was das heißt der
geister rache muss zu sich kommen und
der wird nur erfüllt wenn man den toten
auch sieht sonst ist das rachegelüste
sie die rangliste nicht vollends
befriedigt und ich dachte in einer
amerikanischen rc logik müsste das
unbedingt zu sein
ja ganz wunderbar also würde ich genauso
sagen da fehlte ein ende einer erzählung
die wir eigentlich erwartet haben und um
so kontroverse war die entscheidung der
obama-regierung aber der die die
entscheidung die obama damals treffen
musste war der gewaltsame schossen als
akw anführer von al-kaida im irak ist
vom von der militärregierung der us
militär von empfunden und militär in
bagdad bildlich vorgeführt worden
damit rahmen dieses bild ist umgehend in
den märtyrer fundus von al-kaida- gewann
das wie interessant das heißt in dem
noch fehlenden großen konflikt musste
obama sich entscheiden den rachegelüsten
seiner seiner eigenen gesellschaft
genüge zu tun oder dem märtyrer kult
vorschub zu leisten also es war eine
schwierige entscheide und er hat sich
entschieden das müssen wir nicht zeigen
wir müssen nicht sozusagen triumphale
geste wir haben ihn getötet
super dass wir das ist souveränität
finde ich aber auch richtig für den stau
und zweitens eben nicht diese märtyrer
kult vorschub zu leisten
trotzdem hat da ich war eigentlich ganz
begeistert fand das wirklich eine kluge
und souveräne entscheidung
und dann ist es leider doch nicht dabei
geblieben
die obama regierung hat dann nämlich
doch bilder in umlauf gebracht die zwar
nicht den toten osama bin laden zeigen
aber den erniedrigten nämlich auch
videomaterial dass die navy seals aus
artern bad mitgenommen haben was obama
was obama bin laden von sich selber hat
aufnehmen lassen wo er als ergrauter
erschöpfter mann im kartoffel schlagern
alter mann genau gucken uns noch und das
ist für sie glaube ich ein besonders
wichtiges bild gewesen auch geografisch
noch ein drittes täterbild an das ganz
windschief zu den beiden gezeigten
bisher steht nämlich das bild von zwei
attentätern aus london aus dem jahre
die haben nun wieder etwas dämonisches
noch heroisches sondern das sind zwei
menschen die aus dem schlaf geweckt
wurden und auch angst haben ja für mich
ist das nun ein geschlagen geben das
bild warum ich mich dann systematisch
dieser forschung gewidmet habe und
wahrscheinlich kennen das ich habe sie
ist nicht die zuschauer wahrscheinlich
sie begangen als irgendwann sollte man
dazu sagen 'wow ich habe damals in
england gelebt und ich glaube da ist es
aber auch nicht besonders bekannt ist es
dann in dem verfahren dieser beiden
noch mal wieder aufgetaucht da kam ist
kurz in den abendnachrichten was
passiert ist ist nach dem ersten
anschlag auf die geglückten anschlag auf
die londoner u bahn 2005 gab es einen
zweiten 14 tage später der gescheitert
ist und diese täter war flüchtig und es
hieß damals dass ein flüchtiger
selbstmordattentäter muss die tat wieder
begehen weil das bekennervideo schon in
umlauf ist was ihn sozusagen schon zum
status des märtyrers erklärt das heißt
er muss sterben ist dem tod geweiht
das heißt sie müssen wieder das raase
personen das waren diese person und ich
war zu dieser zeit ja ich war in england
ich musste mit meiner tochter hat nach
london meiner kleinen tochter damals
noch und für mich waren das monster dies
auf das leben meiner tochter abgesehen
haben also die waren in meinem kopf
gewachsen zu unendlichen gold tätern und
dann ich weiß noch genau wo ich stand
und als dieses bild kurz in den
abendnachrichten kamen dass die in
diesem was landenhausen estate
festgenommen wurden
und ich habe dieses ich habe vor diesem
bild gestand und gedacht das kann es
nicht sein ich hatte diese monster und
dann waren diese kleinen wie irgendwie
verunsicherten jungen da auf dem balkon
die offensichtlichen gar nicht geplant
hatten wie es aussehen sollte wenn sie
festgenommen werden wie es sein könnte
wenn sie entdeckt werden
und dann sagt der eine der rechte ja
auch noch
ich habe auch recht aber es ist doch
ganz interessantes kind ja zwei
reaktionen vielleicht auch die nach dem
was für ein mensch man ist vorstellbar
dass einer sagt das sind ja gar keine
monster das den menschen wie du und ich
da könnte sich aber auch vorstellen dass
jemand sagt selbst solche menschen
können es so etwas tun ganz normal
sie sind überall selbst zu einer
normalisierung kann ja auch eine größere
panik erzeugen nicht der dämonische über
verbrecher sondern wir sie ich derjenige
der neben uns steht ja da haben sie
sicher recht
aber ich glaube dass die dass beides oft
hand in hand geht eine dämonisierung
führt dann häufig zu einer
großen angst dass jeder mögliche in der
umgebung der eventuellen täter sein
könnte ich glaube wenn man wie ich dann
so eine normalisierung moment hat also
dieses bild fällt wirklich aus allen
rahmen aus ein bild muss dann heraus
wenn es aber trotzdem passiert unsere
wirkung entwickelt und man mal so ein
schock ins system bekommt und nicht auf
einmal durch die welt läuft wie ich
damals und jeden schwarzen rucksack
träger für einen potenziellen attentäter
hält ist das sehr sehr heilsam
interessant sie sprachen davon dass
dieses bild muster und das ist ja
wirklich interessant für uns selber auch
als konsumenten einzuordnen so wird das
gemacht und wenn man es mal gelesen hat
wie bei ihm im buch dann versteht man
auch und beobachtete selbst ich habe
jetzt selbst letzten tage sagt ja stimmt
so funktioniert das allerdings passiert
ja gerade etwas die staatliche kontrolle
der medien geht verloren es gibt neue
weisen der dokumentation der zirkulation
sind wir in einem bereich in dem dieses
muster doch die stabilisiert wird indem
wir ganz neue weisen der terror
darstellung und der terror bearbeitung
vergegenwärtigen ja ganz sicher also da
sind wir und ich glaube das war mir dann
auch ein anliegen
ich glaube jetzt ist auch der zeitpunkt
sich nochmal zu verständigen wie wir
eigentlich mit den bildern umgehen war
wenn ich einfach mehr nur sagen kann ach
das sind die redakteure acht das sind
die medien auch das sind die staaten die
das klären
es betrifft uns jetzt alle weil in den
anschlägen
das fängt eigentlich schon an bei den
londoner anschläge nder gelangen
erstmals amateuraufnahmen auf die
titelseiten der new york times der
washington post
das ist noch ein ganz nichts sagen das
bild aber ab da kriegen wir zunehmend
sehen wir zunehmend wie sogenannte
amateurbilder aufgenommen werden von
attentaten und dann sofort über die
sozialen medien verbreitet werden also
das für mich für mich wirklich ein
wendepunkt erreicht war wo ich gedacht
habe jetzt muss man hier glaube ich
deutlich werden war 2015 nach den
anschlägen auf die
redaktion von charlie hebdo ein
privatvideo zirkulierte von der tötung
eines polizisten der noch um sein leben
bett der einfach der der mensch ist an
sein fenster der hat sich auch später
entschuldigt
aber man sieht was passiert also der
rennt an sein fenster sieht da unten
passiert was hält die kamera drauf und
filmt eben wie der polizist die kommen
wir zurück um den noch mal zu erschießen
um sein leben bettelt und dann stellt er
das bei youtube erst mal bei facebook
und dann geht dieses video auch gesehen
niemand hier ist gesehen hat kann das
vergessen das geht nämlich nicht mehr
weg und wie schrecklich für die
angehörigen ein dunkler gedanke der sich
in diesem zusammenhang ja anbietet wenn
sie sagen der moderne terror zeigt sich
dadurch zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass
die taten nicht das entscheidende
sondern die zirkulation und wir haben
jetzt eine neue globale plattform der
zirkulation dann müsste man ja daraus
auch schließen das sind sehr gute zeiten
für den terror
das sind geradezu ideale
wachstumsbedingungen für das was der
terror antreibt ja ich glaube den
schluss kann man durchaus 10
das sieht man zum beispiel ja auch bei
dem es und seiner medien strategie die
auf alle kanäle geht also von einem
hochglanz internet magazin über youtube
und immer wenn das geschlossen wird dann
öffnet sich was neues und damit eine
irrsinnige ausbreitung gefunden hat das
ist schon so ja
deswegen ist diese erziehung und dieses
bewusstsein schaffen für die wirkungen
die ja auch immer unabsehbare wirkungen
von bildern sind wahrscheinlich derzeit
besonders wichtig wir wollen doch auf
ein besonders extrem und deswegen auch
besonders aussagekräftigen fall eingehen
wo die spannung zwischen
informationspflicht persönlichkeitsrecht
und auch ästhetischer faszination
besonders starkes es ist das bild des
falling man das ist ein bild von einer
person die während des anschlags als
folge des anschlags aus dem fenster des
world trade centers sprang und es ist
ein bild das auch in ihrem buch einen
sehr großen raum ein
aber nicht gezeigt wurde aber nicht
gezeigt was hat sie dazu bewogen dieses
bild im rahmen des buches nicht zu
zeigen
also das ist ein bild ich bin na ja sehr
vorsichtig und versuche doch schon in
rahmen abzustecken von bildern also ich
finde ebenso ein video wie das da nach
charlie hebdo aufgenommen wenn er hätte
nicht in umlauf gebracht werden sollen
bei diesem bild was ja auch ein opfer
zeigt was nicht gefragt wurde ob es so
in seinem schrecklichsten moment
dargestellt werden möchte und was ja
auch verwandte hat kann man sagen das
ist doch sehr ähnlich warum aber hier
ist für mich entscheidend dass man den
das opfer tatsächlich als person nicht
erkennt und dann macht dieses bild etwas
was uns glaube ich in einer weise noch
mal nahe bringt und das ist auch wichtig
um genau so gut wie wir distanz
strategien brauchen und wie wir uns
politisch über die motive der taten
verständigen müssen in einer
gesellschaft wo man den begegnen kann wo
die grenzen sind ist es glaube ich schon
auch wichtig sich doch auch an
bestimmten punkten das leid was wirklich
durch die taten hervorgehoben wird zu
vergegenwärtigen
wenn ich nun sage aber die opfer ich
möchte nie in so einem moment
abgelichtet werden und anhalten anonymen
breiten öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden
wenn das sozusagen eine grenzlinie ist
die man nicht überschreiten sollte als
absolute genau welche bilder kann man
dann zeigen die light zeigen so dass wir
das doch verstehen es ist wird hier
getötet und es ist eben kein
hollywoodfilm oder video film sondern es
ist realität und da meine ich das kann
man mit diesem bild ja weil es ganz kurz
weil es ist ein wahnsinniges glück der
moment der fotograf hat natürlich
mehrere bilder aufgenommen mit seinem
zeit auslöser und dann wurde dieses
ausgewählte steht da in der luft der
steht fast tänzerisch und auch noch dazu
zwischen die beiden hochhäuser treffen
da so aufeinander dass die eine hälfte
etwas weiß und die andere fast schwarz
wirkt dann gibt es so ein schwarzweiß
effekt und die bänder geben natürlich
den fall vor
obwohl er relativ steht wissen
wer der fällt das heißt das ist der
moment vor dem tod das ist besonders
ergreifend er habe eine kleine
geschichte ziehen ich war von drei
wochen im neuen world center aber dort
wo das world trade center stand im 44
stock und da herunter und ich erinnerte
mich tatsächlich an dieses bild und wenn
man diesen 44 stock an diesem ort jetzt
steht dann kann man auch erst ermessen
was für eine verzweiflung darin gelegen
haben mag dass ich sagen raus zu
springen war das ist wirklich
unvorstellbar deswegen und welche
hoffnung eigentlich in welcher lebens
welle noch noch die hoffnung vielleicht
wenn ich springe könnte ich leben es hat
ja auch noch die aneignung ihr bringt
mich nicht um das ist immer noch meine
entscheidung dass ich springe weswegen
ich dieses bild auch deswegen in
gewisser weise ermutigend finde so
paradox das klingt weil hier jemand
nicht zum vollkommenen opfer wird
sondern immer noch eine entscheidung
darüber trifft wie er diesen attentat
begegnet und wie er sterben will also
aus diesem grunde finde ich dieses bild
auch wichtig nun ist es so dass sich
erstens erlebt habe wenn ich zum
beispiel im vorlesungssaal den
studierenden gezeigt habe diese sehr
sehr emotional reagiert haben
also diese empathisch übertragung von
der wir am anfang gesprochen haben ist
bei diesem bild enorm stark was ja auch
der grund ist warum ich es für ein gutes
bild halte weil wir doch auch verstehen
müssen es ist reales leid und wir
müssten uns irgendwie auch erfinden und
ich denke es ist alles nur ein hollywood
geben
auf der anderen seite ist sofort mit
solchen wirkmächtigen bildern passiert
das oft eine maschinerie losgegangen die
sich um die identifizierung dieses
mannes bemüht hat und zunächst wurde ein
mann in gent ifi zierte dessen familie
völlig aufgelöst war und für die das
noch viel grausamer war als diesen
menschen überhaupt zu verlieren weil ist
ein selbstmord gedanke war und für diese
religiöse familie war das ein tabu sich
vorzustellen dass wir verwandt stadt
sage harrach der katholisch ist ein
selbstmord nicht ist ein tabu genau da
sieht man ethische grenzen an die man ja
selbst im dritten schritt nicht
unbedingt denken wird und auch eine
verantwortung für die betroffenen gehen
an ein leben lang wirken kann
aber nicht so richtig verstehen ja und
dann geht es weiter dann sind neue
identifikation dann gibt es ein
dokumentarfilm also und ich glaube was
das was deutlich wird man kann dieses
leid gar nicht so nah an sich rankommen
lassen man muss sofort jemanden finden
in dem das geschehen ist dann hat man es
wieder von sich weg aber damit passiert
noch größeres leiten dieser
identifikation haben sie denn es gibt ja
die bürgerinnen charlotte klang die
wissenschaftlerin
haben sie denn für sich selbst jetzt im
umgang mit einer problematik die uns
fast täglich bedrängt eine strategie
eine leitlinie gefunden wo sie sagen
diesen bildern setze ich mich aus diesen
nicht ist da gibt es da eine linie wo
sie sagen ja da habe ich halt da hab ich
orientierung
also ich glaube dass ich die für mich
gefunden habe ich versucht die auch zu
begründen in dem buch ich tue mich aber
schwer sie sozusagen in den rand von
gesetzmäßigkeiten zu erheben weil
erstens ist das sowieso keine sinnvolle
strategie in diesem zusammenhang und
zweitens weiß ich immer nicht was passt
die fälle können so sein dass man doch
noch mal anders denken müsste aber was
ist die strategie ok meine meine
leitlinie es also unschuldig als opfer
von die man erkennen kann diese bilder
nicht zeigen weil keiner von uns in
dieser situation so dargestellt und
selbst wenn wir das wenn wir das bejahen
würden wussten wir nicht was mit unseren
liebsten und was dann mit den bildern
passiert das opfer gegangen im
vordergrund und sich nicht das ist das
zweite zum handlanger der täter machen
es gibt auch wie bei den beim weit
verlinken weiterleiten anschauen von
diesen propagandavideos des es wäre das
dann würde man sich zum handlanger
machen und noch viel dramatischer es
gibt ja mittlerweile auch videos von
amateuren die von den tätern
aufgefordert worden sind zu film und sie
aufzunehmen also zuletzt und das ist ein
interessanter fall das world press photo
dieses jahres die ermordung des
russischen
botschaft dass in ankara wie eine
kunstszene sieht das auto täter
inszeniert sich wissen dass die kameras
da sind und dann wird das auch noch ein
world press photo das ist interessant
wir nehmen also ich nehme für mich neben
vielem anderen mit der opfer gedanke und
damit die würde letztlich die
menschenwürde als absolute linie das
bild konsums und die zweite immer die
inszeniert das inszenierungs interesse
so dass wir uns doch überlegen müssen ob
wir als betrachter immer auch zu
mittätern werden in solchen
zusammenhängen
das sind sicher probleme die uns weiter
begleiten würden ihr buch terror wenn
bilder zu waffen werden gibt's dazu sehr
bietet sehr viel orientierung und auch
sehr viel hintergrund zu der will
sprache erscheint es erscheint am 24
fünften das heißt er in zwei wochen
erwarten sie denn auch sagen wir mal
reaktionen wo sie sagen sie werden jetzt
zu dieser person die auch in eine
beratungsfunktion kontron sie sich dazu
ist das für sie eine wichtige funktion
der wissenschaft also das finde ich
schon wichtig also merke auch die
notwendigkeit ich meine immer für mich
offensichtlich ist zu sagen aber das ist
glaube ich immer noch notwendig ich habe
viel mehr angst davor dass ich zum
botschafter dieser bilder werde dadurch
dass ich darüber rede da weiß ich noch
gar nicht so ganz genau wie ich damit
umgehen sind sie denn mit
medienschaffenden in kontakt oder haben
sie das gefühl dass die reflexion ebene
in den leitzentralen der medien
ausgeprägt ist dass sie gut informiert
sind dass ein bewusstsein ausreichend
herrscht die medienschaffenden sind ist
eigentlich in der regel ob sie es
einhalten unter dem wettbewerbsdruck ist
immer noch eine andere frage also der
die presse räte in allen ländern haben
ja auch schon leitlinien die sehr
ähnlich sind
ich unterscheide mich im sinne dass ich
auch findet dass man täter nicht
erniedrigen zeigen soll weil dass der
staat sich da auf ein niveau lässt was
man vielleicht nicht vertreten kann
aber im grunde sind die medien
eigentlich doch finde ich ganz gut
informiert das entscheidende ist jetzt
das ist die so genannten amateur also
wir alle bürger journalisten genau das
bringt uns eine ganz neue reflexion und
auch verantwortungen es gibt ein sehr
schönes bild ein sprachbild von ludwig
wittgenstein der sagt ein bild hält uns
gefangen und das ziel der philosophie
ist es uns von den falschen bildern zu
befreien
ihr buch ist ein beitrag über falsche
bilder nachzudenken und damit auch
distanz und verantwortung zu schaffen
ich habe sehr gern gelesen ist ein sehr
wichtiges buch und ich danke ihnen dass
sie heute da waren ein paar klang und
nächste woche ist er wieder zeit für den
philosophischen stammtisch barbara
bleisch diskutiert mit den stammgästen
und dem medienwissenschaftler norbert
bolz über politische correctness
befördert es den gegenseitigen respekt
oder behindertes das freie denken
wie sehen sie das leben wir in
moralinsauren zeiten oder gilt das freie
wort
schreiben sie uns an philosophie srf
punkt ch und jetzt gleich zeigt die
sternstunde kunst ein film über den
deutsch-französischen theater regisseur
matthias langhoff der mit seinen
interpretationen unsere zeit genau
analysiert und immer mal wieder die
theaterwelt aufmischt genießen sie den
sonntag wieder schauen
[Musik]